what's up angela hey how are you dr john
i'm good how are you
i'm good thank you all for taking my
call for sure thanks for calling in so
what's up
so i have a question about my kiddo this
is
star testing and you just gave me the
hus
feeling for those of you who don't know
the star testing is the texas
standardized
test it's that one obnoxious measure
that they
you just gave me the whole like the
blast
way to go angela all right so your kid
is prepping or taking the
star test standardized test and
i'm sure he's loving it so you're trying
you're calling me to ask how can you
take your kid's love for standardized
tests down a notch is that right
right he gets anxiety about it he's a
good kid he's a good smart kid
and at the school you know the teachers
stress about it and they've relayed that
to the kiddos and at home
we try to calm them down about it but he
still gets stressed about it and how can
we help him with that
yeah i have so many feelings
on this call oh man
all right can i hijack your call for a
second angela
and just okay and then i'll i promise i
promise i'll answer it back in full is
that cool
yeah it's perfect okay here's the thing
um congratulations world we have
sucked all love and joy out of learning
and we've made it about um an end result
right
so here in tennessee my kid just
finished the standardized testing cycle
they got a few weeks after school
you know what they're doing nothing
nothing
they're having parties and watching
movies you know why
because the only reason you shove info
in your brain
is to barf it up on a test that's what
our kids are learning
that the only reason you get info in
your mind
is so that you can regurgitate it for
some
power in your life so that you can be
ranked on a thing
and then once we're done with that you
can do whatever you want
just let's eat cupcakes and run around
like a maniacs and watch movies and
whatever
right so here's the thing i actually
don't mind assessments i think they're
valuable i think they're good
i they come with a couple of caveats
number one
they've got to be fair right some kids
don't know math
some kids are starving when they get to
school in the morning
or they slept two hours last night
because they have a chaotic home
has nothing to do with math has to do
with sitting down and trying to learn
something when their system underneath
them is
is an earthquake right so assessment's
got to actually measure what's trying to
measure um
it's got to assess what it's actually
tried it's got to be fair and it's got
to assess what it's trying to assess
it's got to measure what it's trying to
measure right
so an example of that is if you take a
10 year old
and plop them down in front of a
computer screen for three and a half
hours
and say here's your standardized math
test
you're testing whether a kid can sit
still for three and a half hours you're
not testing whether they know math
right can they sit yeah for a long time
and be focused
not can they actually get the math
concepts right
where does some of the drama from this
come from it comes from i sat with
scholars on this issue i've talked to
some brilliant people i've lived this
issue
my wife's a scholar and some of these
issues when you tie
funding to assessment outcomes
everyone's going to follow the money
that's life that's what we do that's why
we do it
now there's an economic incentive to
drill and kill
we're going to cut out arts we're going
to cut out pe all that stuff becomes a
waste of time
music classes things that we know
pedagogically
enhance and change a kid's brain lets
them breathe lets their brain grow new
synapses all that stuff
we cut all that out because you have to
know these math facts
go go more worksheets more worksheets
more skills more skills more worksheets
and so on
because we've got to follow the money
right
so here's the thing i don't mind
assessments i think they're good i think
they are great
markers of success along a journey right
they're important but they're not the
central orbit your child is a central
orbit
okay all right so thank you for letting
me hijack your call that's me being
dramatic
here yeah um okay so
when you say your kid does stresses what
does that look like
paint me a picture of a stressed out
anxious child
well he keeps questioning about it and
what if i don't do good and what if they
hold me back and i'm telling them that's
not even
an issue um he knows his stuff he's a
straight a student he's 10 years old
but like he's gotten into tears because
he
just stresses about it and i don't i
can't i don't know how to pull from him
what are you stressed about besides what
you've already told me you know
it's you just get stressed about it so
kids kids absorb the tension of the
adults in their life
and then they make that tension their
fault that's all they know right
kids are masters at control you can
control room feels out of out of chaos
i'm gonna smash something i'm gonna
scream and kick and yell i'm gonna throw
a temper tantrum i'm gonna run up and
hug you
i'm gonna make straight a's i'm gonna do
drugs i will get your attention
because i'm gonna control what i can
control and i will figure out a way to
get you right so
when a kid feels that tension when for a
year their teachers have said
if you don't you're getting held back
you're not gonna get into that class
that girl won't kiss you you won't go to
college you're going to be a loser right
all that starts when they're 10
that kid your child absorbs that tension
right and makes the outcome their fault
if i don't my teacher fails i feel
everything falls apart right
so i want every parent listening to this
and you too angela
struggle and connection they're good for
kids i want my kid to struggle but i
want i want them to be nervous
i want to recognize that things are
important and there's certain days you
got to show up and perform that's good
for a kid
but i want them to also know that
they can only be successful in those
things when they're in connection
right that's why the army trains
together as a team you can only go do
great things in battle when you are
know that somebody's got your back right
so
um the first thing is i want i'm gonna
give you like three or four things here
okay
the first thing is i don't want every
parents to fall in a trap around a kid
saying things like this is a waste of
time this is no big deal
this is you know um these things are
stupid
even if you believe them because here's
why you start to pit your kids against
your teachers
all right i mean i'm sorry pit you
against your teacher get your kids
teachers
i'm not being very clear i'm all fired
up about this
if you are going around saying these
things are stupid stupid dumb waste of
your time they don't mean anything
and your kid's teacher is saying this is
everything
yeah you're asking a child to make a
sophie's choice here
who's telling me the truth my mom or my
my teachers
and if my teachers are lying about this
then what else are they lying about are
they lying about the information or if
my parents are the ones that don't fully
get it
what else are they so i don't want to do
that right i want to let them know that
assessments are important and some days
you got to show up and you got to work
really hard
and i love you no matter what happens
right if you
fall apart i love you no matter what
okay so here's a couple of of goals here
number one i want you to connect with
your kid what does that mean
i want them to see mom and dad struggle
on something
right i want them to see them below a
recipe totally screw it up
did you screw up a work report did you
forget something at the store and have
to go
back i want you to take your kid when
you mess those things up
let them know there's a thing i needed
to do and i blew it
i'm totally messed up right and then
i want you to connect outside of the
classroom success with inside of the
classroom success right so that's number
two is
i want you to when he does something
awesome in soccer and
you probably already do this stuff or
when he works really hard to figure out
how to take the trash can out and he's
too short take trash can out and he
figures out how to get it out
that's when you say hey look you do hard
things and i want you to build a culture
of catching him doing hard things and
calling them out
man you figured out how to get the
lawnmower started you do hard stuff
you figure out hard things because then
that language comes in
handy a year later when they sit down to
take tests and you can say
hey you do hard things and use the same
language
and all of a sudden that pattern runs
through your child's mind and they stand
up a little bit taller
because they've got evidence not of when
they failed
but wow so when you tell a kid hey you
make straight a's you have to worry
about this
no they're being told every day you
better worry you better better worry
and so for the year every time they get
straight a's not we knew you could do it
or you're really smart but
you worked hard for this huh or you
didn't have to work hard for this one
and you still managed to get an a is
that right i want to teach them about
hard work
i want to teach them about effort
because if man if we focus on the
process the outcomes will take care of
themselves right
and so then i want to teach them
strategies
right what is it look like when his
little sister is driving in bananas and
you pull him aside and say hey
take a breath a deep breath again we are
building
pictures of things that we can use later
on when they're gonna have test anxiety
or when he becomes a teenager and he has
relationship anxiety
or when he gets his heart broken by some
evil girl and
he has a reservoir now hey you can do
hard things this really stinks but you
got to get up this morning
you got to go to school he's got a
lifetime of mom
pointing out to him man you can do hard
things
right so i want to build this this whole
um an ecosystem where he knows
struggle's good
mom fails dad falls down sometimes too
and they get themselves back up and it's
not the end of the world
i can do hard things and my mom and dad
point it out and call it out all the
time
and then when it gets to this end thing
mom and mom and teacher are in
concert with one another right and then
here's the most important one
no matter what i'm loved
no matter what and if we wait until
hard things show up like honey we will
love you whatever if they don't get that
message in their places so if
honey we will love you no matter what
why'd you you gotta swing like this
you know if we if they get different
messages on a ball field
or they get different messages at the
dinner table
if they hear us talk about dad
like your dad's a [ __ ] what an idiot
and i'm not saying you do this angela
right up
um or if they hear if dads are talking
bad about mom
kids understand there's a point when
mom and dad don't love each other
anymore there's a point when mom and dad
don't like each other and it usually
comes on the back of a bad performance
or there's moments when dad doesn't
think i did a great job playing
basketball
little league or whatever the thing is
so i want to build an ecosystem where my
kid knows no matter what
so i'm telling you angela this is really
really hard for me
because my kids got a lot of tools to be
a great little league player and he
doesn't really care
he just likes running around his buddies
and we will work on something in the
front yard we'll have fun
and man he will be smashing the baseball
and then he'll get up in a game it looks
like
i i don't know what he just stands in a
whole new way
he's just making it up as he goes and
he'll strike out he'll just jog back to
the
back to the dog out like hey everybody
and man when he gets done my first thing
is like dude why didn't you stand the
way we practiced for hours and hours
and i've had to train myself i've had to
like
carry through the shame of this thing
and say my first question is
dude did you have so much fun out there
today yes
awesome that's so good when you came up
to bat were you having fun were you
having fun
you're having a blast and i'm aiming for
what is really important here right i
want him to know there's not going to be
a thing he does i don't love him anymore
now if we set up and work on something
really hard and then he doesn't
um achieve i'm going to grieve that with
him if he comes home and says man i'm so
sick of striking out
i'm assuming that really stinks when you
strike out i've struck out a bunch too i
hate that for you
just like i talked to you about at work
when i screw this up i tell them every
time james is mean to me i tell him man
hon son i i wore what i thought were
good clothes to work today and
i i didn't james let me know that i was
a failure um
kelly let me know hey i know you thought
you had a good answer on that one called
you didn't
you totally you tanked it um i
i need him to know that so that when he
does come to me with the honesty
and let's say man i really failed i
could say yeah i've been there man
remember remember remember and so all
those things together
um one final bonus thing don't be afraid
to look into accommodations to 504
accommodations
some kid needs to take a test by
themselves in a room because they're
actually trying to assess math not
what's my performance and
what's the volume of this room and i
hear all the scratching and clawing
because i'm
hypersensitive in this stage of my
development get your kid the
accommodations they need the 504 stuff
they need if they need extra
time if they need private room because
we're going after
not a race does my kid know math
is my kid no reading right so get them
the accommodations they need
and then teach them sometimes you got to
stand up and say hey i need some extra
help
and that one that ability for them to do
that is so powerful
so powerful moving on as an
old guy who still struggles with asking
for help man and no kid wants to ask for
help it's hard
right so there you go there's some ideas
angela thank you so much for that
bravery for that call
can we please fix the education system
stop tying money to
test outcomes please please please and i
know it's
messy and hard and there is no simple
answers anyone's like i think they
should just you're wrong it's more
complex than that
it is i've sat with the scholars i've
sat with politicians it's hard it's a
mess it's hard
but can we please start teaching kids
that learning is fun and it's
good and it's enriching and it's
beautiful and it's wonderful to change
your mind and learn new things
it's not all about regurgitating and
vomiting up a test
that's all angela you're a stud thank
you so much for your call